Why Allah has revealed four Islamic
books or revelations?
Why did he not complete his religion in
one book as he knows the knowledge of
future? He could have revealed only one
book which could be useful for all the
periods of time like only Quran will be
implemented upon so that there were no
divisions in religion.
First let me correct you with the hers
that Allah has not revealed only four
books. Allah says in the Quran chapter
number 30 verse number 38 Allah says
in every age have we sent a revelation
but by name only four are mentioned in
the Quran. The Torah, the zab, the and
the Quran. Torah is the revelation which
was given to Moses peace be upon him.
Zabur is the revelation given to David
peace be upon him. is the way is the
revelation which was given to Jesus
peace be upon him and Quran is the last
and final revelation which was given to
the last and final messenger prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him but there
were many other revelations besides
these four which are mentioned in the
Quran for example surf Ibraim the given
to prophet Ibraham peace be upon him but
by name only four are mentioned in the
Quran now the basic question that why
did Allah reveal so many revelations why
reveal only one mo and that's it till
jama
It's like my son telling me aba father I
want to become a doctor so why don't you
admit me directly into a medical college
why should I go to nursery then go to
kindergarten then go to first standard
then primary school then secondary
school and then go to a medical college
why don't you give me admission directly
into a medical college so similarly
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala in his divine
wisdom he revealed test what was
required that time first he revealed the
Torah then he revealed
the then he revealed the angel so Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala knows that earlier
if he revealed the Quran people may not
be able to understand it so what has
Allah done Allah knew at this age 1400
years ago at this time alhamdulillah
human beings can understand the Quran
and can follow it and can implement it.
So Allah is divine wisdom because he is
the creator of the human beings. He
knows it. So at the right time when
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala realized 14
years ago that this is the time that
human beings can absorb and can
implement it before that even the other
scriptures
the basic message of was there but it
was different. So 14 years ago Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala revealed the last
and final revelation which Allah knew at
this time the people can understand it
can implement it and follow it. So this
is hmma of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala he
revealed the other scriptures first and
he revealed the last and final
revelation of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
the glorious Quran at the right and
appropriate time. Hope that answers the
question.